what do you learn about human nature if
you step back and look at the big
picture of it that slavery has been a
part of human civilization for thousands
of years that this American slavery is
not a new phenomenon
I think history teaches us a very
pessimistic and a very optimistic lesson
the pessimistic lesson is that human
beings are capable of doing enormous
harm and brutality to their fellow man
and woman and we see that with genocide
in our world today that human beings are
capable with the right stimuli the right
incentives
of of enslaving others I mean genocide
is in the same category right
uh the optimistic side
is that human beings are also capable
with proper leadership and governance of
resisting those urges
of putting those energies into
productive uses for other people but I
don't think that comes naturally I think
that's where leadership and institutions
matter but leadership and institutions
can tame us we contain we can civilize
ourselves and for a long time we stopped
using that verb to civilize I believe in
Civilization I believe there's a
civilizing role Lincoln spoke of that
right so did Franklin Roosevelt the
civilizing role that government plays
education is only a part of that it's
creating laws minimal laws but laws
nonetheless that incentivize and
penalize us for going to the dark side
but if we allow that to happen or we
have leaders who encourage us to go to
the dark side we can very quickly go
down a deep dark tunnel see I believe
that most people want to do good and the
power of Institutions if done well
they encourage and protect you if you
want to do good
so if you're just in the jungle
the so get from a game theoretic
perspective you get punished for doing
good
so being extremely self-centered and
greedy and even violent and manipulative
can have from a game theory perspective
uh benefits but I don't think that's
what most humans want institutions allow
you to do what you actually want which
is to do good for the world do good for
others and actually in so doing do good
for yourself
institutions protect that natural human
instinct I think and what you just
articulated which I think the historical
record is very strong on is the classic
liberal position that's what liberalism
means in a 19th century sense right that
you believe in civilizing human beings
through institutions that begins with
education kindergarten is an institution
laws uh and and just basic habits that
are enforced by Society